when you're in the weeds and you're just
coding and looking at the ui
you don't think about this is a life or
death
[Music]
situation
when the the vaccine stuff came around i
knew
it's do we have the right inventory at
the right place and right time
distribution in west virginia is managed
by the national guard predominantly
you know it wasn't as efficient as we
would like and we were aware of that but
you know we're in a pandemic there's no
playbook here
there were a lot of hands in different
files you know they were working with
excel files
i knew we needed an advanced planning
system and when major costs hit the
ground
he he shot me a text and he said hey we
need a tool
it wasn't even a question of course
we're going to do that
the project started with just giving
them a more automated process
for different groups to submit the data
that ultimately
gave them the information that they
needed to develop their distribution
plan
in our state we have five distribution
hubs if you look at a map of west
virginia you can basically touch
four corners of the state and you're
gonna find a hub and then there's a hub
in charleston
the key priorities were simplicity
right i mean we got to have something
where at that hub level at user level
they just have to log in key any number
and hit enter
and we kind of looked at each other and
said
we don't have time to build a database
we needed something that was cost
effective
but that we could get it up and running
quickly we knew we'd get to a place
where they wanted more visualization
these are government entities there's
not an opening to checkbook this is
taxpayer money
like what can do all of that for us so
shiny just became
the quick and easy solution that came to
mind for both of us
[Music]
we needed to create something that would
ingest had about 10 different people
submitting every week and then
aggregating that information
into an output that would allow them to
make strategic decisions
the manual way at best we would get to
that finished product
sunday night and have to start
operations monday morning
so we're now we have that ready to go by
4 pm on wednesday
the reason we've been able to be
successful i think is because of this
distribution network
knowing where these vaccines are going
at any given point you're going to run
into some problems right where you may
not have
the right quantities necessarily at the
right place so that does require some
what we call inner hub transfer so to
speak based on the tool we built
we're able to provide like visibility
clear through the supply chain
and so we're seeing real time draining
and supply from the hubs
[Music]
in combat i'm moving fuel ammunition
medical supplies maintenance repair
parts
and there's this thing called the enemy
out there trying to trying to take you
out while you're doing it right
i've always taken the approach of if you
can if you can do it in that environment
you can do it in any environment minus
the enemy
sometimes i have to tell myself like no
it's actually a huge feat that we've
accomplished all of this
because it just seems like we've all
been doing our jobs
the entire principle behind this is
build something in an agile manner that
you are going to tear down
and the happiest day of this entire
thing is going to be when you turn it
[Music]
off